yo yo yo what they do man that's your
boy hot cut the phantom you can check me
out on bootleg kev podcast
yo bootleg kev show special guest in
here west orlando
hot boy yes sir what they do what's
going on
hey man it's crazy because i i lived in
a i did radio in tampa for like two two
and a half years
so i used to be in orlando a lot but
it's like 2014 2015.
so like at that time
orlando really hadn't like
popped like it's popping right now yeah
there was like a cat you you do you
remember cassie the white boy from cash
money
so caskey was from orlando
[Music]
i can't really name too much people who
who came up out of who blew up out there
yeah at that point in time like the only
music that was like coming over from
from orlando to tampa was the whoop guy
who obviously just dissed you on a song
so
what happened there what's up because
whoop is kind of like the og in in
orlando and you guys are from the same
area right
yeah yeah yeah both of us from the west
side
what why uh why the hostility on his on
his end obviously i'm not totally hip to
the situation so maybe you can educate
me
i don't even know i don't really know
dude like that
that's what i'm saying
i don't even know bro like that so
because he's kind of like older right
he's been doing
music a lot longer than you obviously
right yeah
i mean i just know like when when i was
living in florida which was like six
seven years ago he was the name out of
orlando you would hear yeah
so i would say like probably the
previous generation of orlando music
obviously he's still active shout out to
whoop but like yeah so you you don't
even know him like that for him to be
really having an issue as you know what
you're saying that's over yeah that's my
y'all no i don't know girl like that
how um you know you're out here uh the
hall of fame tour shout out to polo g
yeah how's that tour been
it's been it's been lovely though but
you know you know uh i'm still kind of
it just started right
now it started like i'm going to say
about two to three months ago but we
went on a break um cause the road so
like the second row wrote because i just
saw the flyer and it's like this is like
the second or third date on the flyer at
least no just the second
it's the second flyer that's what i'm
saying it's like the second leg of the
tour yeah
what's it been like obviously because
you're pretty much the main support for
the tour like what's that been like you
know because polo g's fans are insane
yeah his fans crazy too and it's crazy
because
a lot of them are is hip to my music too
but i want to say all of them like you
know how everybody in there they came
for apologies to all them know send me a
song but i say a decent amount of people
uh they'd be rocking with me you know
i'm a rocket regardless though but they
they be rocking with me yeah this is my
first tour this is your first official
tour yeah cause i'm sure you've been
getting the back end the bags getting
the brown bags you know doing the
florida yeah i've been circuit and all
that yeah i was doing see
i went through the whole florida but it
was it really was no tortoise it's just
spot dates yeah so this is like yo you
guys got a you guys got a bus or a
sprinter or what no one got now we
flying she's flying day to day wow
so now that you've gotten your first
tour like what is something that you've
learned about
maybe like
traveling or just because i feel like
the live show is one of the more
underrated most important parts of like
any artist's repertoire like is there
anything you learned about performing or
no doubt like like like boom
like i just be i just be learning [ __ ]
like
like when i when i watch
like because boom my set right before
polo jesus right so after my set i'll
sit there and watch his set and just be
learning like a little certain [ __ ]
like like boom
like his dj
his dj
his dj like do certain [ __ ] they be like
damn my dj should do that it's like
little [ __ ] like that right let's be
learning [ __ ] or like learn like
how how he interact with the crowd cause
you know you know
tour different from clubs
totally different clubs is like you pull
up the dj throws some [ __ ] on you do two
or three or four records then you you
back your section like boom it's not
even though
i do perform at clubs like i perform at
my best like i perform at a tour but
it's like the club not really focused on
performance it's just like vibe it's
just i don't know but tori you got a
real deal performed you can't just sit
there and end it ain't nobody on stage
with you yeah like ha ha and everyone's
looking at you you performing at a club
yeah it's like you're one of the things
going on yeah people are there partying
people are in there with their you know
trying to get on a shorty like people
are in their section
when you're on stage people are
everyone's looking up at you
it's like a different type of pressure
um what is it about orlando because i
feel like right now orlando is one of
the hot pockets in music that like
you know jacksonville is another one
obviously
alabama's got a wave going right now but
like orlando i feel like historically in
hip-hop hasn't really had like a lot of
national representation
what do you think it is about orlando
that is kind of like y'all's time right
now that like finally people are coming
around and paying attention to your city
now i think a lot of people been been
paying attention i'd say like
we had we had a couple come come out of
our lender but in like
like one got no mega star well i
remember like back in the day the other
person i forgot smiles in south star do
you remember smiles in south star that's
two people it was two people it was an
asian dude and a black dude in like
early 2000's they had a record i'm i'm
born
i was born in 2000 that's what i'm
saying
that's all this is way before you even
thought about rapping
but like i can't think like i think like
yourself glock 9 pooty like i feel like
like this wave of orlando's the best
uh
you know it's been at least national
yeah as far as attention
yeah to my out of orlando right there
yeah i don't know orlando yeah most def
i could say that too i can say that how
much does like
because orlando
culturally is such a different place
than like next door is like polk county
right and the next door to that is tampa
and if you were to go from like tampa to
orlando to like the clubs
it's like day and night it's like you
would think that you're in a whole
different region of the country because
orlando
feels like
it just feels a lot different than a lot
of other parts of florida like like how
different is because
i mean because i know this like as a
club dj i know i could dj at club sky in
ebor city in tampa and play certain [ __ ]
that'll go crazy but if i go to orlando
and dj
downtown orlando
a lot of other [ __ ] will go up that
wouldn't work and it just feels like as
close as everything is things are still
like really really different yeah
i don't really i don't really know how
like no other city is for
i don't really be in no other cities
like that
south for like miami and [ __ ] right
so but it's funny it's crazy i saw you
walking uh when i went to rolling loud
in miami uh earlier this year and
we
you were like walking out while i was
walking in
so i saw you how was uh how was the
experience at rolling aloud
you were also just kind of kicking it in
my yeah you were just kind of kicking
and watching the show too at certain
points cause i remember seeing you in
the vip area yeah i was not miami lit
though you know florida don't [ __ ] with
me you know they you know that so that
that was lit though miami was lit 100
man um
you have the same management shot to
100k management as a lot of other dope
artists but uh no notably uh mellie yeah
um we actually did the
the last y w melee interview before he
turned himself in yeah um
what what would you ever have a
relationship with him or yeah see me and
mele
like
i think it's about like 2015 that's when
i went to my program so i'm saying i
went to my program
uh mellie went to a program too but he
was in there with people from their own
stuff and they'd be like oh mellie asks
about you really ask about you whatever
around that time in both of us was like
rapping
just not starting to get our buzz like
around the same time but boom yeah
mellie was asking about me you know i've
never seen mother before
so you guys have never actually
physically met nah
but you guys were both locked up at the
same time it was locked up at the same
time okay boom got out separate places
though
yeah he got out then i got out shortly
after but it was like boom
bro was like he was grinding though i'm
when i was in the program i was watching
him
yeah i got out i'm watching them
i'm like damn that way taking off you're
going crazy
but you know mellie gonna always show
love
saying so many milly uh [ __ ] around he
put my name in the song
but i ain't i ain't noticed i ain't
noticed i got out i've been saying
really i'm like huh go to it i'm like
yeah that's real but we never seen each
other we're under the same management or
not i don't talk to me before we got a
song or not you guys have chopped it up
like someone of course yeah got like um
two songs what was the line that he
dropped your name in he says uh
switcheroo
just like hot boy
my first song i ever released cause were
true that [ __ ] went crazy
like that [ __ ] went crazy that was like
my first song i released though
yeah no it's crazy because like
he got so i mean he was already
his trajectory was crazy but then him
getting locked up if it feels like
he he never got to experience like
being his like he got bigger once he got
locked up if that makes sense yeah
yeah now milly was already he was
already there no no he was there no he
was there but i just mean like i feel
like a lot of the riaa certifications
came after he got locked up like you
know what i'm saying like it was like
yeah yeah like a lot of plastic yeah
yeah yeah yeah no it's
it seemed like a nice dude man um
with which is you i mean obviously shout
out to dolph what just happened with
dolph i'm wondering like you know what
happened to nipsey out here are you at
at home a lot do you still stay in
orlando cause i always like i always
feel like
when you stay where you're from
it's the hottest for you if that makes
sense
yeah do you do are you still in orlando
i live everywhere though
okay i love everyone do you find
yourself moving like differently when
you are back home though because you
probably have more
haters there more people who are kind of
gunning for you like at home
yeah but like i move like that all the
time though
i move like that all the time so i ain't
like i'm
you know like it's new to me or not like
ain't like i gotta go change up how i'm
moving because i'm down
i move like that all the time
yeah orlando for people who think it's
sweet like obviously
people who've never been to orlando
think of disneyland and they think of
yeah you know you know every city got
they they cut apart everybody every
every city they street parts every
single thing they street part the rich
part of the yeah
projects mm-hmm every every city got out
of yeah no i've been uh i i i love
orlando have you ever been to do you
know who mike busey is no okay man i
gotta tap you in with the homie mike
busey
mike busey got a uh what that is he got
a mansion and i think it's in kissimmee
or it's like
what do you do
he's just a
he's a wild boy man so this guy mike
busey he lives in like he's from orlando
he's got this huge mansion called the
sausage castle who just shot a video
there
joyner lucas just shot a video there
post malone's shop videos there it's
like uh the white trash
playboy mansion plies has shot like
three videos at this dude's crib
i gotta tap you in you go over there
there's like 50 like [ __ ] strippers
alligators pigs all kinds of other
bro
bro it's insane bro it's like it's like
an orlando area delicacy for those who
know about it it's like some if you know
you know type [ __ ]
put some wild nights there to say the
least but
a lot of people go over to his house
because he's got like a crazy gun
collection
and they'll shoot videos there he's got
flamethrowers and
[Music]
again midgets you know what i'm saying
and just break there's regular women
there as well cool
[Laughter]
i'm cool nothing against nobody but i'm
cool i don't even know if we could call
midgets midgets i think uh that's i
think that's frowned upon little people
little people little people man um
yo this record you got with future is
going crazy yeah it's going crazy in the
club
do you feel like this is like for you
because i i feel like this was your
first because i've been paying attention
to your [ __ ] for a minute but i feel
like this record with future is the
first record of yours that i felt like
kind of started to hit over here in the
club on the west coast like that made it
this way like you got probably bigger
records streaming-wise and like
youtube-wise yeah but i feel like in the
club as far as like crossing
over on the west coast i think so too
though i think that's the same thing
though
it feels like it right because i'm like
man i have people who hit me in the club
like i don't hear this record now people
will be calling me
people never called me from down here
saying oh they they playing it but
people have been calling me like their
commonwealth's playing his own
script club saying all that so that was
kind of like all right i see i see now i
see what it's doing
like this is like some scripted [ __ ]
like for the scribbles or something yeah
it's really some club [ __ ] though let me
take that back now no scribble [ __ ] like
it's it's a club here um what was
what was like did
you know getting a future on a record
what was the politics behind that did
you have to drop in the bag was it some
love [ __ ] had a little bit of both i was
like when he heard the song he just he
was like he wanted to get on that bear
but when i made that song it was on some
future [ __ ] so it was crazy that he was
he picked that song we sent him like two
songs
probably like
he picked that one like
he told me he's like like that melody
like
type [ __ ] then he's just telling me like
let's certain [ __ ] about it
did he uh give you a discount for the
for the future did you have to did you
have to come out of pocket for a future
feature no i just told you how i went so
he just did it
yeah oh that's huge and he did the video
yeah that's crazy that's big man
yeah that's love yeah no
no no he is a real one shout out to
future and then the record with tj just
dropped which is going crazy
you be staying on your video [ __ ] man i
feel like you drop visuals consistently
yeah
like you don't like let nobody forget
about you you know what i'm saying i
can't though that's what it's about
though
putting it in a face you gotta you gotta
be right there yeah like is that
something that you conscious like like
you do on purpose like make sure that
like yo we keep feeding feeding the fan
base if this is what you if this what
you doing it's like why not
do it hey what you what you sitting
around waiting for yeah i got videos all
in the cut
i could drop every day of the week right
now if i want to that's crazy i got
stuff in the cup i just sit on it
wait so
it's better to have it than to not have
it 100 percent man um you've obviously
had some records with uh obviously shout
out to push ice the free push ice yeah
you know you got a couple records with
mellie um
what is it about
it
yeah free mellie i mean you know
obviously with going through your legal
situation recently
have you kind of like did that i mean
obviously you had like you said earlier
you've been locked up previously but
like with what happened recently did
that kind of refocus you on what's
important like maybe like make your
circle smaller
did that kind of change anything you're
doing as far as how you move or
maybe the things you talk about
not really like hot when i talk i don't
talk about crazy stuff but
yeah like circle wise not really though
cause you know you always well me i'm
always analyzing seeing what i can make
better because you know people ain't
perfect so if you like
then once you be [ __ ] up you keep
[ __ ] up just start to sit back and
analyze
then you gonna move a certain way
yeah i mean when you when you get like
certain [ __ ] that you can't jeopardize
like if you leave or something
what what's what's going to happen with
this to this person yeah so just think
about that [ __ ] are you on the other
side of your situation or is it still
open
you know on the other side like it's
always of the legal [ __ ] yeah every yeah
obviously
i don't really want to speak too much on
this right that topic though yeah that's
fair and when you feel comfortable with
me trying to 100 man it's just crazy
because like you know it feels like now
rappers are targets like you can't even
can't even make music dangerous that's
the most dangerous job in the world yeah
i feel like
you got to go to clubs you got to
like you dropping your location off from
the beach
[Music]
and then you know people
they just think rappers be
and they
they think i don't know i feel like
people just feel like rappers like
you know they don't deserve all that
sometimes well that is true right if you
really think about it if you have
enemies you openly advertise where
you're going to be often
like right and then on the other end
for whatever reason
legally all kinds of [ __ ] like
artists like music gets combed through
and i feel like artists are an easy
target for any sort of like agency who
wants to just pick on somebody you know
what i'm saying and yeah
on both sides of the coin i just feel
like it's like it's like a tough
position to be in at times and people
don't even realize
yeah that's most definitely the most
dangerous thing though do you ever feel
stressed out like like [ __ ] man i'm
stressed or you you know what's because
i'm a rapper yeah man i mean [ __ ] you
obviously got some like pretty public
beefs that have what happened and not
not it's not even about that though i
don't think i'll be stressed because
like
a lot of fake stuff
be going on
like just just fake stuff like just
because who you is people certain people
might hit you up then you might feel
like it's real love but end up not
it's like um
who has uh been an artist that's reached
out to you or that you've worked with
that you feel like has been real genuine
love that came from a real place because
you have a lot of music with a lot of
artists
yeah but i don't even got a song i'd say
30 big 30 big 30. yeah here real
i don't even got no sun with him yet
he's just tapped in with you though yeah
who we were talking this [ __ ]
he dreaming though
yeah i mean even like shout out to uh to
the whole city over there because like
obviously you gotta recognize pooh
scheisse that went crazy the malcolm x
which was a crazy video by the way
appreciate it yeah yeah what was uh how
how was the like link up with pooch iced
tea because that was well that was about
a year ago so that was how was that
damn
time's been flying man what
damn how was that
damn how the [ __ ] did i meet pooh shasta
instagram maybe
i don't i don't know but i know i've
been [ __ ] with his music though
i just got hooked onto his music
damn i don't know but we we we clicked
too
damn bro
it's all good if you don't i don't need
to remember
the guy
um
you had a a situation that went viral on
instagram
where you and the island boy kid got on
ig live together because he was locked
up with you i guess
the dude with the blonde dreads
with the
so now this kid
and his brother are like viral as [ __ ]
because they have that you the island
boy kids i mean i obviously you you it
was it's been it was it was um someone
who i guess you was locked down with
but now the kid's viral as [ __ ] nah i
won't lie no
no no no dude name that
it was the uh
what's the [ __ ] name of this kid bro
you guys are on ig live together talking
about the dorms you guys are in
i think his name is fly soldier
it's like him and his brother and
they're [ __ ] they're like tick tock
memes now
you've seen the island boy dudes right
no
i think i did hear them though i think i
did though
wait hold on time to stop the interview
because we gotta talk about our good
folks at odd socks man listen if you go
to
oddssocksofficial.com that's
oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword keyword it's a [ __ ]
promo code use the [ __ ] promo code
bootleg kev alright at checkout you'll
save 20
off they got i mean look at these
spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg cab at checkout save 20 off man
shout out to our family at odd socks if
you support us go support them uh what's
the deal like um i always feel like you
know there's always kind of like a lot
of
energy out there how's your relationship
with the other guys in orlando at the
moment as far as pootie glock nine like
is everything
kosher is it in the air like how's the
relationship with those guys there's
never no pressure like it was it's not i
don't got pressure on nobody i don't got
nothing with nobody i don't got nothing
going on with nobody does it feel better
to like
move like i feel like when you're in a
city like orlando that doesn't really
have like a national identity in hip-hop
like it's probably better if everyone
just kind of moves
together if that makes sense like the
way atlanta you know i feel like atlanta
a lot moves kind of
in the same direction like you all see
yeah you'll see the amigos and 21 and
gucci and everyone works together you
know what i'm saying
everybody worked together on that too
though but it'd be like i don't know
taste some real [ __ ] though okay boom
down there's like
like okay boom everybody we everybody
start from the same spot whatever right
we at this level everybody at this level
and it's like boom
[ __ ] will see like damn
bro on the level up higher than me
damn he just went up another level
higher than me you see him saying
and go to hayton
so now loki they still like their player
like okay yeah
we dogs or whatever
but be hating loki
and that's just throwing [ __ ]
that's how [ __ ] we going down there
on some real [ __ ]
i feel like that happens a lot in a lot
of situations yeah but that's like
i know working together on they'd be
like damn
that should just be i don't know i don't
even really want to get into detail
about this [ __ ] but you got you get it i
hear what you're saying it does feel
like in the smaller places like
i guess jacksonville is a great example
where it's like yo if everyone just
moved in the same direction and like
showed love
i mean jacksonville's wild that shit's
crazy down there but
it feels like in the smaller cities and
like it's a crab crabs in a bucket type
of mentality whereas opposed to being
happy for a peer of yours
yeah and being genuinely happy for them
instead you feel some type of way
because it's not you
yeah i mean that should be crazy
[ __ ] crazy uh
with uh polo g you know polo's like
somebody who obviously is a very very uh
he's got his head on his shoulders um
good kid man like is there has it been
anything you've learned from him
personally like just being on the road
with him being close to him
outside of the live [ __ ] we're talking
about just like maybe how he does is
like handles certain [ __ ] or has he
given you any game because you know he's
he's on a crazy level right now as far
as success yeah
one thing i pulled up he like he don't
talk a lot though
you know i i used to be like that but i
used to think like damn i can't be no
rapper and be like that right well look
at brad up there you see what i'm saying
he done blew weight up and still like
that but still you know you still got a
politic or whatever he i'm pretty sure
he'd do that but other than that he'd
just be like to himself like
anti-socialism loner tyson yeah
i think it used to be a problem when i
used to be like that
some people be like that and people take
it the wrong way when it's just really
just how they are yeah and i learned
that too i learned that too that you
can't always take be getting emotional
when someone yeah on the same vibe as
you bro [ __ ] a [ __ ] ain't in front of
just
do it be this just because they quiet or
whatever they ain't talking on there
they don't mean they don't [ __ ] with you
that's probably how they is yeah i'm
saying
um obviously because of getting a
feeling it's like oh bro
he thinks he's too good or he's a weirdo
it's like man sometimes just people
ain't gonna they they got their own way
they move don't [ __ ] with me see i'm
saying people
just jump jump jump to conclusions that
aren't necessary crazy [ __ ] is there
gonna be a body of work coming from you
soon
body work like an album mixtape yeah
yeah cause you're putting out a lot of
music
yeah i drop on to 10.
on the 10th coming up
what's the name of the project
um
i i know i lowkey want to just pop out
with it okay i want to pop out with it
yeah so we'll find out when it comes out
yeah okay
that's fine i really want to tell you
the date either though well the 10th is
coming you told us already
hey being in the south you had to have
been some sort of fan of dolph man where
were you like when you found out dolph
passed and like you know what was your
reaction
hmm what's me in the south i mean like
obviously
coming from florida i know dolph was big
in florida like did you come up as a fan
of him and like what did he do i played
some songs by him like when i was in gym
and stuff i used to play wear music i
just play songs
and like dolph harder was that like like
uh when you found out he passed like
like how did you feel i mean i you know
i know a lot of people [ __ ] up crazy
it was like just crazy
it's like
a lot of people just be dying in their
own city so it'll be like
and it'd be rappers like that not people
but right now yeah man that [ __ ] we like
happened to x happened uh
just thinking about it
and it should just it just make you
think about that [ __ ] though thank you
like yeah
be your own city sometimes
be your own city most the time what
unfortunately man
that's all i'm saying like it's gotta be
like
like better sweet to be back home
because you're like yo if i'm home in
orlando it's it's home but it's also
where you probably have the most
ops
yeah
[Music]
not even off just haters that's it yeah
a lot of people don't beat opps
they just be haters yeah but but if they
but if they talk to you they'll show you
love to your face but they'd be hating
on the side for sure yeah now them be
your fake brothers
them be haters
the ones who show the fake love and be
your brothers and stuff
your fake brothers though got you
um on the 10th when we get this project
that we're not getting the name of uh is
there going to be any features besides
the features we have obviously a little
tj i'm sure that record will be on there
um any other features
i'm gonna just pop out with it this is
just coming yeah okay mellie
i'm gonna just it's gonna come it's
gonna pop out all right
it's coming man it's on a [ __ ]
way it's on the way have you uh i know
you did a record with dred shout out to
young dread but like have you tapped in
with any of the other like obviously
tampa's right next door like you know do
you get into tampa a lot do you go
you know tampa's got some crazy clubs
and got a crazy scene bubbling as well i
feel like they're kind of next up
low-key yeah
now i i i [ __ ] with temple though i
[ __ ] him but that's the only artist i
did i'm sorry
somewhere from there
a young jury
yeah shout out to dread he's like og out
there so yeah forever
uh what else is like with now that you
got money coming in now that things are
going well are you investing in anything
yeah
yeah
like really i'm just investing in my
people who
who trying to get their stuff going
so like maybe someone wants to start a
food truck you'll be like hey look
yeah type [ __ ] like that like i want to
be able to go to my family like hey let
me hold 50 right cuz i click
type [ __ ]
that's what's up man so the album coming
out the 10th be on the lookout
uh anything else on the way
yeah
my project that's the only thing that's
it the project
oh
videos you know that already though
bunch of videos
no
we're just coming with it and then uh
being focused though right now though in
20 so we're about to be the end of the
year right so what you like if you had
to like say what are your goals like
let's say i'm talking to you one year
from now in 2022 what would you have
hoped happened next year like what are
your goals for the new year man
goals for the new year is just
no
i'm just trying to have all my people
rich
and i want to have more kids more kids
yeah
how many kids you got now only got one
so you're trying to just spread the seed
yeah with the same baby mama or you want
to switch up the baby mamas this time
i don't know i i i don't want to be in
right now though are you you got a good
relationship with your baby mama yeah
that's important i don't know
because if you have a bad relationship
you can make your life hell
yeah you might as well just keep all the
kids with the same girl right like you
might as well
keep everything i got one big one right
now
maybe two soon
nah nah nah nah just keep it all
together with the with the so more kids
more music more money next year yeah
there it is man well look i appreciate
you pulling up west orlando in here hot
boy that's uh bullet cat podcasts
boom